find your thing when you're trying to
win the career lottery sometimes the
winning ticket is right in front of you
the answer to your most pressing
questions and the path to the work we
were born to do may come from the people
you interact with every day everyone's
an expert at something is a good
principle to keep in mind and often that
something comes as a surprise but even
if you know what your skills are a skill
is only as valuable as the extent to
which people will pay you to use it how
do you figure out which of your skills
are most valuable marketable here's the
core principle when you're not sure what
your thing is when you don't know quite
where to look to find that job or career
that brings you joy flow and a good
income the people you talk to every day
can help you find it the answer may come
from your inbox whether that inbox
consists of the actual emails you
receive with the same questions over and
over your social media feeds are just a
conversation to have with friends in
other words the people in your network
we actually have a better sense of what
your most marketable skills are then you
do the key is looking to the questions
they ask you the favors a request of you
and maybe even the books or articles
they send you simply because they think
you'd be interested when someone says
hey can I ask you for a favor and you
already know what that person is going
to ask you you have your answer think
about it if you have trouble updating
your phone whom did you ask for help if
you've been going to the gym but not
seeing results whom do you ask for work
out advice when you're planning a trip
abroad and need to find a hotel who did
you ask recommendations now think about
it from the other perspective does
everyone ask you for help updating the
phone or improving a work Adam or
recommend in a place to stay while
traveling if you look closely you'll
probably find that there are certain
types of advice that people asking for
over and over whether its
recommendations for books and movies
investing tips or your thoughts on the
latest gadget they hit the market the
advice people solicit from you is
huge clue as to which of your skills and
expertise is most in-demand and
therefore probably the most marketable
find your thing
[Music]